ein herzliches hallo und einen
wunderschönen vormittag hier also
unserem trainingsbereich gestern haben
wir noch ein theraband word und
wasserflasche werk hat gemacht heute
sagen wir drin in einem tierisch guten
rumpf krafttraining das heißt hasen
salamander enden werden uns begleiten
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und
trainiert gescheit mit die nici ich da
peter wir sind wieder da für euch und
wir haben heute einen speziellen gast
einen sehr erfolgreichen judokämpfer den
christopher wagner
aber christoph bitte stell dich kurz
davor dass nur drei untergebracht und
der südstadt und machen okay was sind
deine begleit sportarten zum ausgleich
was machst du unter anderem liefern
jetzt muss man mit fb2 maske ja wiederum
ein schlagwort mein stichwort wir sind
alle auf das krone virus wieder getestet
worden heute in der früh und
selbstverständlich wieder negativ
gewesen das heißt auch wir können den
abstand entsprechend verringern anders
wird der skipiste
da ist beim lief dann stand immer die
maske zu tragen ok dann fangen wir an
mit einer kurzen kurzem abnicken muss
cool gab es bereits gestern alles gut
verkraftet bis super dann fangen wir an
mit einem kurzen mobilisieren
christopher wie macht ist der junge
kämpfer wie mobilisiert der sagt es
gelingt durch bewegen
ich höre du sagst tschudow ich sag ja
was ist da die richtige aussprache also
beides wäre das heißt wir haben ja wir
haben ein
wir haben hat ist vielleicht oder nehmen
wir gerne schauen wir dass man den
kreislauf in schwung bringen bewegen uns
gern mal laufen anstand
wie gesagt wir machen heute ganz viele
übungen aus dem bereich rumpf kraft da
fange an im aufwärmen dann mit einem
etwas anderen zeit programm der
christopher als leistungssportler
natürlich hat ganz andere muskuläre
voraussetzungen wie wir auto
normalverbraucher das heißt er zeigt uns
dann einen rumpf kraft einen rumpf kraft
zirkel wo man 30 sekunden belastet und
direkt wechselt ohne pause das war so
nett markt wir haben aber natürlich auch
die zweite variante die etwas einfachere
die für alle ganz gut passen wird ok wo
mobile weiter genau weiter bewegen uns
viel am boden natürlich auch und
entsprechend wird das handgelenk da auch
belastet werden machst du das vom
wettkampf alles mobilisieren oder nur
vom training
also wir wissen ja schon die philosophie
jeden tag genau aber im speziellen von
wettkampf und vom training okay das war
bereits zu mobilisieren der gelenke ist
ganz wichtig um die gelenkschmiere
richtig herzustellen und die flüssigkeit
ins gelenk zu bekommen dass die das eis
gleitet dass es entsprechend nicht
kannte
sollten wir denn noch schmerzen haben im
schultergelenk und die beweglichkeit
eingeschränkt sein dass grund von einer
verletzung lasst die ein oder andere
übung einfach aus rein prinzipiell ist
aber dass am kreisen für die
schultergelenk überhaupt kein problem
berichtet
genial gleich genau eine vor eine zurück
okay und wir bewegen uns wieder ganz
locker am stand schauen wir mal ob der
judoka schattenboxen kann das haben wir
nehmen die ganze woche hat uns dazu
begleitet das heißt lockerer lockere
schattenboxen lockerer boxer lauf genau
funktioniert genauso gut sowie bereich
zu hause einfach machen geht schon darum
wie boxer aufhörte zeit nehmen wir uns
20 30 sekunden überhaupt bewegen
ok wieder mobilisieren wo machen weiter
oberkörper bewegen oder hüfte kreisen
wir haben gemacht keine kreissägen macht
große kreise richtung wechsel nahmen
linke richtung drehe name die rechte in
die rechte richtung drehen aber die
hüfte und und die gelenke kann man ja
eigentlich im sitzen als gut
mobilisieren oder sagen wir vorher
gegeben sogar mieter genau lockerer
spagat und einfach die fußspitzen nach
innen und nach außen fallen lassen
einfach hin und her bewegen und das
super mobilisation für das hüftgelenk
werden anziehen die bei einer nach ihnen
veranlassen okay das haben wir
einerseits und hüftgelenken andererseits
kann man natürlich auch schon im bereich
der lendenwirbelsäule hinein dass das
einmal in der mobilisation ein unteren
rücken bereits trainern
es ist die versammlung und links rechts
super was man hätte ich sag stehen wir
wieder auf und bewegen uns noch mehr
anstand mit dem anspringen überzeugt
dass der kreislauf in schwung kommt weil
dann der wechsel auf nieder belasten
bewegen das braucht man an gut
vorbereiteten körper und wieder kurze
pausen mit durchschlafen größter fall
was wird uns noch vielleicht die gelenke
ungelenk so genau wann der einrichtung
aber wenn der andere erkennt die
variante auch schon im einband stand die
haben mal die letzten tage immer wieder
gemacht das heißt wer gleich die sich
dann auch diesen mit fordern möchte kann
natürlich das kniegelenk weiter hoch
ebenso dass er in auf einem bein
eben wie gesagt steht mit christoph von
allgemein kann man hätte also ein
größeres gelenk richtig danke das
kniegelenk war es das wetter vorhersagen
haben dann unterbrochen
machen wir nur ganz kurz ist nie gelernt
dass man das andere mitnehmen
denner und eine übung zum aktivieren
braucht man auch das heißt einmal in die
liegestütze ausgangsstellung und den
marken klar das heißt dynamisch das
klinik vor sodass man kreislauf und
stütz kraft wärme aktivieren als
vorbereitung was jetzt kommt 531 und
pause ihr kenzler auf der matte bleiben
30 sekunden haben wir gemacht belastungs
zeit und dann haben wir nach 30 sekunden
pause zeit das verändern heißt das ganze
das heißt wir gehen jetzt da hinein da
christoph rau hat sein programm so
gewählt dass sagt er möchte 30 sekunden
belasten für die vordere kette 30
sekunden direkt im anschluss die
seitliche kette wiederum 30 sekunden
dann rückwärts und 30 sekunden die
andere seite das heißt zwei minuten hart
vor spannung in der rumpfmuskulatur
das macht man mit dem langen hebel und
mit dem kurzen hebel nicht auf dich
bitten den langen hebel vorzuzeigen
ja da kriegst du von macht mit euch den
kurzen hebel bei ihm kam es dass das
kann die nici macht es perfekt da und
sagt euch das jetzt einmal vor langer
hebel wechsel in den unterindizes dass
man einmal die positionen wechseln
wechsel in die rückwärtige position
jawohl und noch mal auf die seite und im
optimalfall berührt nix anderes den
boden außer der ellbogen und fuß wenn
die zwischendrin mal mit dem mit der
hüfte absetzt ok fast nicht gedanke ist
es sicherlich kein problem aber probiert
mal das gesäß in der luft bleibt die
hüfte in der luft bleibt okay jetzt
bereit ihr zuhause satz bereit wir
fahren an
in 20 sekunden ich sage ich immer wieder
die zeit dazu und entsprechend schau mal
dass man diese zwei minuten als
vorbereitung für das was dann kommt
gemeinsam durchziehen zehn sekunden auf
position einnehmen
ja die nie gemacht bitte den kurzen
hebel und der krise davon macht den
langen hebel bereit 21 uhr los geht's da
erkennt die positionen kniegelenk bzw
sprunggelenk hüfte und schulter eine
edle
und wenn es jetzt auf dem christopher
schwarz er hat ein ganz leichte steigung
nach oben drehen das heißt wenn jetzt
ein ausbessern wollte das trainerteam
bisher spur unter perfekt und wir haben
unser ebene wieder genau so ist es
dann haben wir das weiß der christopher
natürlich nicht euch auch angeraten die
ellbogen parallel zu halten weil vieles
schwieriger wird ok 30 kunden macht sich
bereit für wechselt 216 genau der winkel
im kurzen hebel im kniegelenk zum also
unterschenkel zu oberschenkel 90 grad
dann habt ihr gute stabile position und
der lange hebel um entsprechend mit dem
kniegelenk in der luft zehn sekunden
und wie gesagt atmen ganz wichtig weiter
atmen ruhig weiteratmen sauerstoff in
die muskulatur hineinlassen drei
sekunden und wieder positionswechsel im
optimalfall ohne dass ihr das gesäß
absenkt und donnerstag ganz wichtig
laufen kriegen davon ja da kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule das heißt
der blick geht nach oben um das becken
wird wirklichkeit hoch gedrückt gerne
stehen aus der schulter herausheben und
dann haben wir auch wirklich coole
position dass der teich wirbelsäule auch
entsprechend entlastet ist nur fünf
sekunden 321 und positionswechsel
genau die nicht gerade trinkflasche
forum schließen ja ich dass ich wieder
auf und gleich eine erinnerung für alle
die unseren beitrag teilen und
kommentieren
ihr nehmt seit heute wieder an der
verlosung unserer trinkflasche teil
kleines souvenir kleine anlage eine
kleine erinnerung und wie gesagt teil
kommentieren sagt erledigt sei es aus
zwei minuten belastung für die
rumpfmuskulatur kann man mal kleine
haken drunter machen wir machen einen
zweiten durchgang nach einer kurzen
pause und den dynamisch das heißt da
kriegst du vertragt euch die varianten
dynamik gleich vor mit langen hebel und
das gleiche macht man natürlich mit
kurzen hebel die dynamik wären wir da
auch hineinbringen dass der vertrag
anbieten sagt einmal ganz kurz vor ihm
unterstützt denn er kennt die variante
beine heben bereits es gibt natürlich
auch die variante arme heben wichtig das
becken bleibt stabil
genauso ist es in der seite 2 was gibt
es da ja das kann man beim heben genau
volle stabilität aus dem unteren bein
aus der seitlichen muskelkater und beim
abheben und auf der rückseite was machst
du genau aber bitte wieder den blick
nach oben ja genau
und dann haben wir einen grad der
heißeste ag kurz durchschnaufen
macht euch bereit in 30 sekunden machen
wir die zweiten 20 minuten als
spezifisches aufwärmen das was dann
kommt keiner gern daran schluck trinken
wie gesagt außerdem an kristof wilke
zeit verbringst du mit dem cross
training pro woche pro woche naja pro
training eigentlich einmal so einmaliger
zirkeltraining pro krafttraining also
zweimal die woche
ok also das ist schon beachtlich und
vielseitiger als judoka sanierungs kraft
trainiert die brauchen wir ganz wichtig
position einnehmen zeit läuft 30
sekunden und los geht's dynamisch hände
strecken wichtig becken bleibt gerade
mit dem kurzen hebel oder mit dem langen
hebel ermittler christopher
wenn es für euch zum haushalt zu viel
isst bleibt sind das tat ich lieber
sauber ordentlich in der statik arbeiten
als wie schlampig in der dynamik ak 10
sekunden und dann den wechsel wieder und
versucht sie wechseln ohne dass ihr mit
dem gesäß am boden ankommt wechseln auch
hier die dynamik das bein heben oder
eben auch das becken abheben aber wie
gesagt in dem fall machen mal die
variante beim hochklappen halbzeit schon
wieder vorbei erst nach zehn sekunden in
dieser position noch drei sekunden und
position wechseln durchbeißen zwei
positionen hammer notiere position
rücken genauer blick nach oben kopf
entspannt becken schon hochdrücken und
die zweite variante das becken heben mit
den versen am boden mit der schulter
kopf am boden
das ist die etwas einfachere variante
die genauso dynamisch gut funktioniert
und für das gesäß rückenstrecke also für
die gesamte muskel kette auf der
rückseite eine gute variante des
trainings ist jetzt noch fünf sekunden
bis zum station wechsel bereit machen wo
einst ein wechsel genau jetzt setzt die
rolle von der rückseite bis jetzt hat
sie immer die vorderseite gesehen
stabile position aus dem oberkörper
heraus da bewegt sich kaum was also das
bein auf und ab das die stabilität aus
dem rumpf ist sehr gut aber wo anders zu
erwarten
von einem super erfolgreichen judoka wie
gesagt em dritter bei der
europameisterschaft am protest das ist
hervorragende leistung seines
kurzauftritt ausgang
ich hoffe ich geht es noch gut zu hause
ihr habt noch ein bisschen kraft in der
rumpfmuskulatur über man jetzt fangen
wir an mit dem richtigen
bewegungstraining ja wie ich gesagt habe
erste übung entengang zwei varianten
variante nummer eins ist ganz am boden
variante nummer zwei hinter so weit
unten wie es möglich ist okay sagen wir
das noch bevor christopher wie schaut es
aus wie sehr ist ganz unten hände bei
den schläfen und marschiert nach vor
je nachdem wie viel platz gehabt und
auch wieder zurück jänner sehr gut danke
schön
nickel für dich die zweite variante
nicht ganz so tief unten mit dem gesäß
funktioniert akut und wieder zurück was
haben wir dafür muskulatur die
hauptsächlich beansprucht wird natürlich
die oberschenkel müssen da wirklich
unter feuer stehen richtig also
muskulatur aus der wade heraus genau das
ist ein großer punkt da und die
beweglichkeit aus dem sprunggelenk kann
man natürlich in der position auch mit
dabei während es immer so gestalten ihr
probiert es zu hause haben wir aus ihr
schaut das in die opposition hinein
findet und dann wären wir ungefähr 30
sekunden belastungs zeit machen da
kriegt man von mir wieder ein staat und
ein stopp positionen hätte gesagt
einnehmen
sieben sekunden fünf sekunden statt mal
los 321 händen
wichtig dabei versucht mit den versen
aufzusetzen
das heißt dass sie entsprechend über die
straße auf kommt und dann ab und nicht
nur auf den zehen oder am fußballen euch
bewegt das wäre wichtig eine
informationsreihe das nachzumachen so
ein paar sekunden wenn es noch geht
bleibt nur ganz kurz und ansonsten auf
auslagern beiname ausschnitt und nicht
gepasst danke marschiert wie die ente
maschine vor zurück ohne pause
oberschenkel aus lockern was heute für
die namen der hase okay das heißt wir
schauen wie könnte der hase ausschauen
wie für position so wie vorher und die
beine sprechen quasi bis zu den händen
hat vor und wieder zurück wobei hat nun
ihren hasen rückwärtslaufen sehen aber
für unser training nehmen wir das jetzt
einfach an alles okay christa versagt so
dass andere märkte mit dynamisch beine
ganz nach vorn
ja war super der hamster wesentlich
zweite variante aber das ist nicht das
problem die die was von der
beweglichkeit her
kleine einschränkung haben lassen
einfach das gesäß ein bisschen höher und
die die von der beweglichkeit hat der
top drauf sein die können natürlich mit
dem weser ganz untergehen
ok hasen position was ich wieder sorgen
sie ausgangs position einnehmen und hase
läuft
ich gebe inzwischen damals die marten
weg gebrauchen jetzt kurzzeitig nicht
dann haben wir mehr platz als 30
sekunden lang gläubiger vor bei 56
sekunden
das ist schon richtig ansprechend aus
also da sein name ist so lieblich aber
die übung ist richtig anstrengend
okay aber leute es geht noch
anstrengender dass wir gleich sehen ja
jetzt haben auch meine mit den
salamander christopher sagen sie mal
bitte den salamander in seiner urform
vor
ja aber eine liegestütz abwandlung mit
vorgreifen mit körper nachdrehen
vielleicht das seitenarme 90 grad drehen
bitte genau spitze ok und jetzt da die
das zu hause ausprobieren und sie denken
bei der ersten position wie kommen immer
hoch was kann man da machen sagen einmal
vor ihr kennt immer liegestütz wochen
das ist überhaupt kein problem normalen
lebens immer machen den hammer schon
ganz oft macht aber die variante hände
wechseln handy greifen im unterschied ja
auf den knien das wäre so angelehnt
nicht gedacht gebieten zuvor als braucht
die tomaten doch wie das vorweg land
genau füße also knie am boden vor
zurückgreifen
genau und mit der hand wechseln da hat
man seine angelehnte variante die gema
er hat die kammer machen und den ist
einmal richtig wissen wohin warst du
dann gemütlich wird es richtig wissen
wohin machen wir mal den klassischen
salamander und da jetzt keine gender
problematik auch zu haben unsere dame
ist bunten hort und banken stark die
zeigt er jetzt die salamander variante
hardcore vor macht es 30 sekunden und
bei christa vor der fan szene kann es
auch aber der macht mit euch die etwas
abgeschwächte variante
seit bereits zehn sekunden dann legen
wir los hätte ich sag' positionen einmal
grob einnehmen
fünf sekunden 1
genau vorgreifen zurückgreifen mit
vorgehen nach dem becken tief lasten
tiefe liegestütze im unterschiedlichen
griff vorwärts rückwärts perfekt 15
sekunden oder es wird richtig anstrengen
das ist wichtig sagt ja noch 5 4 3 2 1
eine ausnahme ausschnitt und den mann
jetzt hauptsächlich natürlich dort voll
unter strom
die sind richtig belastet worden nimmt
sie eine kurze pause bringt suzuki war
okay war anstrengend ja die kleine frau
das war ja fast alles okay was haben wir
es nächstes salamander haben wir ab
gehandelt was können wir noch machen
gehen wir mal ein dschungel super den
gorilla wie schaut er aus den
vierfüßlerstand ja okay okay da passt
kann bei die eine seite hand und fuß
geht gleichzeitig nach vor und zurück
gorilla wie gesagt mitten im dschungel
wo wir zusammen aus ok wie gesagt eine
hand ein bei nimbuzz gang und nicht im
diagonal dem was man gewohnt sein dass
er leicht die koordination an mit dabei
wir starten wieder los position 321 und
gorilla geht
genau bei mir würde schon sagen dass
silberrücken geht weil vermutlich hätte
zwar doch einiges jünger seien aber zu
wissen warum die vorzeigen und
kommentieren ja weil sie konnten auf 5
sekunden und sein aus 30 sekunden gibt
spürt es in panik spürbar in der
rumpfmuskulatur generell christopher du
spielst ja ok das heißt mitten von
barilla jetzt weg was machen als
nächstes wo kommen wir hin
wir gehen einmal in die erde oder auf
die erde in unserem boden herunter
der käfer käfer haben wir also eine
bauchmuskelübungen genannt ist
anscheinend ein sehr beliebter begriff
für diverse übungen
jetzt müssen wir wirklich ganz genau
hinschauen weil das ist eine übung die
hatte ich vorher auch so noch nicht
gekannt bitte christa versager mal vor
den käfer so wie du ihn kennst ok einmal
von der seite das heißt das becken und
der oberkörper verdrehen sich gegen
gleich und mal wandert quasi am boden
hin und her okay was probiert das glück
heraus also ich habe tränen gelacht und
ich spreche jetzt hat koordinativ ist es
nämlich gar nicht so einfach nicht übers
bieten für zweite variante die
koordinativ das jetzt in der schnelle
nicht umsetzen können
genau wir haben das rad fahrer
bezeichnet gegen gleich ellbogen und
knie zusammenführen das ist qualitativ
die wesentlich einfachere variante auf
die er natürlich entsprechend auch
zurückgreifen könnte würde mich freuen
aber wenn ihr die käfer variante unseres
judokämpfer star genauso ausprobiert das
heißt bitte einmal dann die positionen
einnehmen käfer und radfahrer treffen
sich oft in der natur aber auch
miteinander heute nichts zu tun
fünf sekunden und dann statt mehr los
321 das richtige dynamik drin ich hoffe
dieser kammer ein video erkennen
käfer marschiert vor zurück vor zurück
das schaut super aus und hat natürlich
einen extremen trainingseffekt auf die
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur
das haben wir super super intensiv
drinnen also
für jeden der seine seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur richtig fordern möchte
der käfer die perfekte variante fünf
sekunden an durchhalten durchbeißen und
sei dies aus das war der käfer was
weidmanns 9
jetzt waren wir am boden unten wo gehen
wir jetzt einige die raupe
wahrscheinlich gleich groß ja und in der
gleichen position am boden die übungs
aber trotzdem ganz anders als das waren
wir das gleiche kann natürlich jetzt
nicht bieten unter dem gleichen namen
wie schaffe ich es ok versuchst du mal
in die ausgangsposition den liegestützen
zu gehen und da umfang war und jetzt da
marschieren die beine nach vor oder und
jetzt geht der körper wieder nach einem
gestützt und wieder nach vor und das
ganze natürlich wenn das wohnzimmer von
platz zu ende ist geht natürlich einen
retourgang das heißt unsere pace wieder
vorwärts und rückwärts unterwegs genau
wie gedanke stellen
wer hat ein kleines problem wiederum mit
der beweglichkeit hat geht ab bislang
winkel ins knie hinein
das ist in ordnung wenn man die
beweglichkeit so toll wie die niki hat
dann kann man natürlich die beine
ansprechen durchgestreckt lassen welche
variante magst du bei einer
durchgestreckt oder leichten winkel in
den beinen
na na na na na wenn es möglich ist
einfach die beweglichkeit entsprechend
umsetzen was drin ist rhynern okay da
ist nicht schwieriger und lockerer
das ist einfach komplexe übung und das
schau mal was drinnen ist staatenlos in
fünf sekunden hätte gesagt und los
geht's
wenn es körperlich zu intensiv wetter
kann natürlich den liegestütz entweder
am kurzen hebel machen wie sie schon
kennt oder den liegestütz anfang haben
wir weglassen und nur noch vor und
zurück marschieren das ist auch möglich
ein problem
30 sekunden zeit ist aus dirmstein hat
ausgedient
super jetzt war natürlich cool wenn man
auf die raupen hin wenn schmetterlinge
machen könnten
sonst aber nicht wirklich wenn also auch
nach dass körperliche aber wir bleiben
am boden wir bleiben beim geht ihr was
sie auf der erde bewegt ganz weit unten
willkommen zuspielerin also ich bin ja
besonderer freund von spielern aber wie
geht's dir damit braucht man nicht
unbedingt aber es ist natürlich ganz
nützliche wichtige tiere und wir
simulieren setzt in unserem training ja
wir schauen wir daraus was machen wir da
die links liegestütz rücklings position
genau da so nach vorne
ihr kennt diese position bereits von der
brücke die immer gesagt haben ja in dem
fall ist aber das gesäß jetzt nicht ganz
hinauf gedrückt und das becken gestreckt
sondern in dem fall ist dass der propos
knapp über den boden und versucht ihr
die spannung entsprechend zu halten
genau noch vor was treuen der
bauchmuskulatur und dem rumpf ablesen
was ist noch da das schauen dass wir die
letzten körner anna aus ergibt und dass
man richtig tolles training gemeinsam
geschafft haben okay gesagt position
einnehmen und die spinne geht
normalerweise rückwärts quasi oder aber
das richtig im kopf hast du bleibt
bleibt äußerst gut ja vor und zurück wir
machen beide varianten auf nummer sicher
ok 5 sekunden und anstatt mal wieder
position einnehmen becken hoch und 21
spiele läuft
die frage ob die spinne jetzt schon müde
wird oder geht's nach einer spinne ist
noch voller elan 5 sekunden und sei es
aus so leute und jetzt haben wir noch
eine allerletzte übung für euch die
bitte bisschen mit vorsicht genießen zu
hause vielleicht etwas herr niemann
weiter anhalten kennt wenn es notwendig
ist ja und zwar ist es das schon okay
wir schauten dass störche aus niki was
macht man da die stadtwerke haben auch
in erinnerung die haben ja letzte woche
einmal gemacht und das ist jetzt so
quasi eine super dynamischen stand waage
vor und zurück und forum zurück super
danke
wem das etwas zu viel isst oder der
alles so viel platz zu hause zur
verfügung hat christoph was kann man da
für variante anbieten so stehen im
einstand nach vorsprüngen das stand war
dass der schwung bei nato so mitnehmen
ist eine möglichkeit genau oder ihr
probiert es einfach wieder in der statik
im gleichgewicht zu sein und lehnt sich
ein stück nach vor und schaut es einfach
das gleichgewicht halten ist genauso gut
ok letzte übung 30 kunden länger los mit
dem stark zu
und keine sorge in unserem volk dass
dort keine kinder gleichgewicht
wiederfinden zurückspringen genau immer
aus einem kontrollierten gleichgewicht
herausarbeiten
dann haben wir gleich das training von
letzter woche mittwoch aber mit dabei
sein so motorik reich gewicht halten
muskuläre ausgleichsbewegungen sander
natürlich nicht dabei
noch fünf sekunden dauern zeit ist sehr
gut
ja weil leute das war das
trainingsprogramm von heute vom mittwoch
unter dem namen einem training oder eine
moves ja wir haben einen ganzen haufen
tiere mit dabei gehabt ist einfach was
gibst du den leuten mit im lok dann ja
was sollen sie machen was ist wichtig
wenn ich die leute daheim sitzen und das
ganz wichtig die bewegung das komme in
die natur in frische luft in die natur
ok also wie es die ganze woche bereits
gesagt haben ihr müsst euch bewegen
rausgehen drin es ist nicht egal aber es
ist wichtig dass ihr was tut nur der
schluss tut da entwickelt sich was ohne
sich zu bewegen bleibt man genau auf dem
stand wo man halt jetzt ist ja und das
wollen wir nicht wir wollen ja die zeit
sinnvoll nutzen
und wenn man schon nicht entsprechend
raus kann weil man eben im lokal uns
befinden dann machen wir die bewegung
der sport der salat das frei ja okay das
war's für heute
training abgeschlossen ich freue mich
auf ein intensives training auf ein
intensives workout im bereich military
fitness sowie letzten donnerstag auf
morgen bleibt gesund und wir sehen uns
morgen um 10 uhr 30 zum nächsten worker
dankeschön und schienen backen